so
my buddy ryan holiday had a series of
books still does where he takes the
ideas of the stoics
and he applies them to contemporary uh
terms he has this whole cottage industry
that he's doing very well with
and i'd asked him years ago if i could
do that with camus and he's like sure go
for it
and i was going to rework camus the myth
of sisyphus
and i read it recently i reread it and
this wasn't the book i remembered at all
and i'm like okay i'm going to write the
book that i remembered but
the more i was writing it i one of the
things i always yell at conservatives
about there's a long list
is they don't talk about the great
victory of conservatism
which was the winning of the cold war
without firing a shot
and i said you can't expect the new york
times to tell this story because the
blood is on their hands
and i'm like well michael
instead of complaining about it why
don't you do it why don't you talk
that is a great example of the good guys
winning over the bad guys
and that's become a it's
the victory is beautiful but also
pointing out to p when people are like
oh things are worse than they've ever
been
they don't appreciate how bad things
were in the 30s
uh what stalin was doing overseas and
how people in the west
were advocating to bring that here so
that's kind of pointing out how bad
things were
and how good they became and uh
you don't have to be a republican or
conservative to be delighted
at the collapse of totalitarianism and
the peaceful liberation of half the
world so that's a picture of the good
guys winning oh yeah well how does that
connect to sisyphus
and uh maybe to speak deeper to
[Music]
life and the whatever the hell this
thing is
which is what i remember the myth of
sisyphus being about so
where does the threat of camus sort of
uh
lie in the work that you're doing so the
myth of sisyphus
what i had remembered correctly is
actually just a five like
seven five to seven page uh like coda to
the whole book at the very end like you
only need to read that little essay
called the myth of sisyphus
the broader work is about camus concept
of the absurd
and the absurd man within literature and
he goes and it's just like i don't
really care about
this character in dostoevsky and all
this other stuff that you're talking
about it's of no
relevance but what he the myth of
sisyphus the myth itself not the book
or the or the essay of his is this greek
character
and sisyphus is forced in hell to uh
roll a rock up a hill for attorney at
the very last moment the rock falls away
and camus take away from the story is
that we have to met
we must imagine sisyphus happy and there
are several interpretations of this but
one is
once you accept that you are living
an absurdist existence once you own
your reality it loses its um
bite and you can start with that
as your kind of baseline and bite
is suffering and hopelessness
so i i think when people
look at how much ridiculousness is
happening in america and it's escalating
you could either think oh all is lost or
you can and i think you and i have lived
our lives like this you can live life
more like a surfer
whereas you're never going to control
the ocean but you can sure enjoy that
ride
and stop tr if you're trying to control
the waves yeah you're done
but if you're like all right i've got my
board i'm going to see where this takes
me
surfing from what i understand is a
pretty fun activity
and also sometimes dangerous but you'd
have to ask tell us about that
you